the world's a simpler place when you're
young where you only worry about what's
for dessert or if you can stay up past
your bedtime life is good unless you run
into a bully bullies suck plain and
simple
but we've all had to deal with them they
use size power and fear to terrorize you
into doing what they want
now give me your lunch money
you end up having to hand over your
allowance and your homework just to
avoid a beating now i never did but i've
seen it happen now we like to think that
as we get older we outgrow our torturers
but we really just call them by a
different name
because isn't a tyrannical leader just
another version of a bully they use the
same tools to force you into submission
you can't do or say what you want
without being afraid of the consequences
if you tell on them you end up getting a
swirly
[Music]
try to talk and you get silenced
sounds pretty similar to communist china
but the only way to defeat a bully is
stand up to them not everyone's brave
enough though but the special ones are
like the protester who refused to move
aside for the tanks in tiananmen square
or the patriots at the boston tea party
who wouldn't give in to king george's
demands
or ralphie from a christmas story who
had just about enough of scott farkas
[Music]
something had happened a fuse blew and i
had gone out of my skull
if you do nothing and you live in fear
your bully will continue to control you
at a certain point you got to take a
stand
they may take our lives
but they'll never take
in washington a brave group of high
school students are having their william
wallace moment we told you about them
last night their state requires every
student k through 12 to be masked up all
day every day
even though science says it's wrong
funny how quickly the left abandoned
follow the science when they didn't like
where it led
but thankfully these kids
aren't staying silent anymore
and we're all walking into the school
with no mask on
you can get me in trouble they can
suspend me i don't care we're done with
this
and obviously all of you are too we want
this to be a peaceful respectful
movement we are just trying to gain back
our rights as citizens if a staff member
asks you to put a mask on you say no
thank you and keep walking and if they
kick you out then go home
brave words from some young kids
and it looks like they're not alone in
this fight as students across the nation
from california to missouri have refused
to surrender to their mask masters
we're just out here protesting uh
the school's mass policy i just came out
and i said that i wasn't gonna wear a
mask somehow we can find a way to make
some sort of compromise
with the school so that kids that choose
not to wear a mask can make their way to
school that's all these kids are asking
for the right to go to school this
shouldn't be that hard
we started this week by telling you
about america's great awakening over
covid crime and counterfeit news and now
we're seeing it in the classroom
hopefully
it's not too little too late because
masks aren't even the weirdest things
some kids are forced to deal with one
school band has been making their
students practice while stuffed into a
plastic tent
i'm in a glass case of emotion
i hate to tell them but it might make it
hard for the woodwinds to do their thing
as they require you know some actual
wind and air to play
but science is hard for the left
the year's been hard on everybody a long
island teacher got caught perusing kinky
toys in front of his students
i guess it was good that they had their
masks to cover their eyes
so this is just a little thing that the
school is going through these days in
loudoun county virginia ground zero of
the school wokeness revolution an
assistant principal is actually
threatening students with jail time if
they show up without one
until you arrive your children will be
held in an in-school restriction
situation here at school they are not
allowed on campus or on loudoun county
public school property
starting tomorrow it will be considered
trespassing trespassing is a felony
offense in virginia think about it for a
second
but you throw on a dress and rape a girl
in a bathroom
cover that right up
and if you want to see some real
insanity just slide
one state south north carolina where
they're trying to indoctrinate you
before you're potty trained
mass compliance later down
their their growth as students right so
when they're
at it's like if you're a two-year-old
you're trying to help them practice for
age three and then four when they're
going into pre-k classrooms and then
from there trying to help them get into
normalized situation wearing masks
potentially in a kindergarten classroom
and so forth right so that's what we're
trying to do and it's
it is with a developmental lens and not
a you must do this or else lens two
years old slap a mask on your face and
learn to hate your own race and your
nation
but the great awakening is here
it's time to take a stand against these
bullies
[Applause]
we're not saying get violent you know
what we're talking about lucky for
america there are a few real-life peter
parkers out there fighting back
this is just the beginning hey sean
hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to fox news youtube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else